عندما أركبها أشعر وكأن
كل شيء آخر يغسل بعيدًا ، لا شيء
مهم بخلاف ما
أفعله هناك ، فهذا أفضل شعور على
الإطلاق بشعور الحرية من كل شيء
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي مارك بومونت وأنا
رياضي التحمل  مع الرقم القياسي العالمي الحالي
لركوب الدراجات في جميع أنحاء الكوكب
بحثًا عن المغامرات وإيجاد القصص
هو السبب الذي يجعلني أكثر شغفًا به
منذ أن أتذكر أنني كان لدي هذا
الشعور بالفضول حول العالم هذه
المرة لقد
عدت لأفعل ذلك.  سألتقي دونا ، راكبة دراجات
كانت مصدر إلهام للفتيات الصغيرات في جميع
أنحاء الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، ولدت وترعرعت في
دبي ، لذلك عشت هنا لمدة 25 عامًا
وأنا أركب الدراجات الترابية منذ أن
نشأت هنا والدي  علمتني دائمًا
كيفية ممارسة أي رياضة
أرغب في القيام بها ، لقد نشأت وأنا تعلمت أن لديه
سيارة يدوية تعمل على لوح التزلج ، أشياء مثل
التي لم أشعر أبدًا بوجود
أي شيء لا يمكنني القيام به لمجرد
أنني فتاة هناك  الرياضة التي أريد أن
أتعلمها تعرف دعونا  اذهب إليها ، لا يوجد
شيء يعيقني عندما بدأت في
ركوبها ، شعرت أنه من الطبيعي أن أفعل ذلك
أيضًا ، لقد أحببتها منذ
البداية لذا بدأت في السباق في
بطولة الإمارات الصحراوية وهذا
سباق مدته ساعتان مثل سباق 20 إلى
حلقة 25 كيلومترًا وكنت أقوم بها مع
اثنين من هؤلاء ، ثم بدأت في
الركوب قليلاً على مضمار الموتوكروس
وأرادوا حقًا أن تشارك المزيد من الفتيات في
السباقات ، لذا شاركت في
سباقين للموتوكروس ثم شاركت في رالي واحد
كان دبي  الرالي الدولي
وربما كان هذا هو السباق المفضل لدي على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]
عندما أخبر الناس عن ركوب
الصحراء ، أصفه نوعًا ما لأنه
يتصفح في الكثبان الرملية ، يبدو الأمر كما لو كنت
تقطع الزبدة في
الماء ، فهذا يبدو طبيعيًا جدًا حقًا
تشعر وكأنك فقط ترسم لوحة
قماشية وتجد خطوطك وعندما
تجد هذا الخط الجيد ، يبدو الأمر
وكأنه حركة شعرية كما لو كنت تتصفح
الكثبان الرملية ،
يكون مجتمع الكتابة هنا مثاليًا تمامًا.
ProjectSyndicate ar وأرحب به لأنهم في
الواقع أكثر فائدة لأنني فتاة ،
فهناك العديد من الجنسيات المختلفة
التي لا تشعر أبدًا بأنك لا تنتمي
إليها ، كمزيج بين نوع من الضحك
والرعب ، نعم أعني أنه
ليس من قبيل الطفولية  إنها فقط
حقًا ، لماذا واصلت المضي قدمًا ،
أعني أن الكثير من الأشخاص بدأوا شيئًا ما
، ثم عندما يعود الأمر إليهم ، فإنهم يفعلون
شيئًا آخر يا حبيبي ، لقد انتقلت إلى
المستوى التالي ، لقد واصلت المضي قدمًا لأنني
أعني بالنسبة لي أنه كان شيئًا  لقد
غيرت حياتي حقًا في الوقت الذي كنت فيه في
مكان مظلم تمامًا لم أكن واثقًا من
نفسي ، لقد جعلني ذلك نوعًا ما أدرك مدى
روعة الحياة حقًا إذا
لم تعطيك الصحراء والدراجة شيئًا
آخر تلك العبارة التي أظهرتها
قد تكون حياتي رائعة ، وهذا سيكون بمثابة ريح كافية ، كما
تعلمون ، إنها أفضل هدية
يمكن أن أطلبها ،
أود أن ألهم فتيات أخريات بشكل
صحيح إذا كان بإمكاني إعطاء فتاة أخرى تلك
التجربة التي مررت بها وهذا
الشعور بالثقة بالنفس التي تنتمي إلى ذلك  صنع
اليوم الذي قضيته في القلب حزينًا ، تذهب إلى
شخص لطيف للغاية ودود للغاية
ويريد ببساطة الانضمام إلى الدراجة ولكن
منافس شرس مثل أستطيع أن أرى أن
التيار الخفي لأريد الصبر
لمجرد مواكبة ذلك حول
الجن كان مخيفًا بدرجة كافية
أعني أنه كان رائعًا
، كان الأمر مثيرًا للاهتمام ، لقد كان مخيفًا ولكن
كان رائعًا حقًا
[موسيقى]
أنت